dégoûté longtemps pour comprendre que vous
savez que nous avons fait plus de conceptions de ce
personnage et je pense que beaucoup d'autres
provenaient de problèmes de voulions-nous
qu'elle soit dégoûtante ou dégoûtée, ce qui
semble être une question simple mais ce n'est
pas nous l'avons fait  quelques premières explorations où
nous avons essayé de dessiner comme des
personnages dégoûtants et cela n'allait pas fonctionner
pour les appels ou vous connaissez un
personnage qui vous attirera
mais j'ai l'impression que chaque film a ce
personnage qui comme rien ne colle
c'est un peu comme un grand va-et-vient
Chris a également fait une très bonne
exploration juste en trouvant des images de
gens dégoûtés Je pense que les
gens ont juste eu cette chose commune ou
c'est comme si j'avais remarqué que c'est comme
cette tête en arrière et comme leur main  c'est
presque comme s'ils voulaient vomir
mais ils ne peuvent pas et c'est un peu
comme si j'avais mis cette écharpe là-bas,
c'était peut-être qu'ils pouvaient jouer avec, c'est
comme si elle n'avait pas de collier mais
peut-être qu'elle h  annonce cette écharpe ou elle
essaie constamment d'aimer
vomir ouais elle est tellement dégoûtée par ça